Optimisasi klasik adalah langkah penting dalam algoritma kuantum-klasik
seperti variational quantum eigensolver atau quantum machine learning.
Tapi seringkali meminimalkan
fungsi yang rumit di ruang parameter berdimensi tinggi itu susah banget.
Nama saya Victoria Lipinska, dan di video ini kita akan menjelajahi
rutin optimisasi klasik untuk algoritma kuantum-klasik.
Masalah optimisasi itu nggak gampang.
Semakin banyak parameter, semakin banyak pula kemungkinan
kombinasi nilainya, dan pertumbuhannya itu eksponensial.
Dalam catur, misalnya, ada 64 petak
dan masing-masing pemain punya 16 buah. Setelah masing-masing pemain menggerakkan satu buah,
ada 400 posisi berbeda. Setelah dua langkah ada 72.084 posisi,
sekitar 9 juta setelah tiga langkah, dan sekitar
280 miliar setelah empat langkah.
Kalau sampai 40 langkah saja, jumlah posisi yang mungkin
diperkirakan sekitar sepuluh pangkat 120.
Bermain dengan sempurna butuh menjelajahi semua posisi yang mungkin,
dan pertumbuhan yang luar biasa ini artinya memeriksa
semua posisi satu per satu itu nggak mungkin dilakukan.
Ini bisa diatasi dengan memecah masalah jadi dua sub-masalah yang lebih kecil.
Pertama, kita perlu menentukan susunan papan catur mana
yang kemungkinan besar muncul di langkah-langkah berikutnya.
Ini yang kita sebut subspace yang menarik perhatian kita.
Kedua, dari subspace itu, kita tentukan langkah terbaik apa yang harus diambil.
Ini yang kita sebut langkah terbaik.
Dalam analogi ini, pencarian awal melalui subspace yang menarik
adalah analogi dari algoritma optimisasi klasik kita.
Setelah subspace yang menarik itu diketahui,
algoritma kuantum biasanya bertugas menemukan langkah terbaik
dari subspace tersebut.
Kita mulai dulu dengan satu parameter saja,
theta, yang memparameterisasi cost function yang ingin kita optimalkan.
Kalau kita plot fungsinya, misalnya tampilannya seperti ini,
di sumbu-X ada nilai parameter theta
dan di sumbu-Y ada cost function-nya.
Perlu diingat, cost function bisa berupa biaya finansial nyata
yang ingin kita minimalkan, atau seperti yang sering terjadi pada variational quantum
eigensolver, bisa berupa energi yang diminimalkan oleh alam.
Tujuan kita adalah menemukan theta
yang sesuai dengan cost terendah.
Kita mulai dari nilai theta awal, dan di setiap langkah optimisasi
kita cari theta baru yang terus menurunkan cost-nya.
Kelihatannya kita tahu ke mana harus bergerak kalau bisa melihat grafiknya.
Tapi sulitnya optimisasi adalah kita sebenarnya nggak bisa lihat itu.
Kita cuma tahu nilai cost-nya — sepotong kecil dari keseluruhan puzzle —
setelah kita evaluasi fungsinya pada theta yang dipilih.
Begitulah cara kerja optimisasi secara umum.
Optimizer mengambil sampel parameter theta lalu menghitung cost-nya.
Seperti yang bisa dibayangkan, memilih theta secara acak untuk merekonstruksi
seluruh topologi fungsinya itu nggak efisien sama sekali.
Makanya, optimizer yang cerdas akan mencari
gradien fungsinya di setiap langkah.
Dengan begitu, optimizer tahu ke arah mana di plot itu
harus bergerak untuk menemukan cost yang paling kecil.
Begitu gradiennya nol, algoritma berhenti,
dan minimum sudah ditemukan.
Minimum ini belum tentu minimum global.
Bisa jadi itu minimum lokal,
artinya itu nilai terkecil dari cost function di sekitar area itu
tapi bukan yang terkecil di seluruh rentang theta.
Untuk satu parameter, itu tentu saja mungkin terjadi.
Tapi semakin banyak parameter yang kita punya,
semakin kompleks fungsinya.
Dengan dua parameter saja kita sudah punya permukaan,
dan dengan empat parameter, kita bahkan nggak bisa menggambarnya lagi.
Sama seperti contoh catur, mereproduksi semua kemungkinan
dengan cepat jadi nggak bisa ditangani.
Kita lihat bahwa meminimalkan
fungsi rumit di ruang parameter berdimensi tinggi itu memang susah.
Tapi supaya hasilnya masuk akal, kita ingin optimisasi klasik
bisa berjalan dengan cepat sekaligus akurat.
Selain itu juga harus tahan terhadap noise,
yang bakal punya pengaruh signifikan pada komputer kuantum jangka dekat.
Algoritma optimisasi klasik secara umum bisa dibagi
jadi dua kelas: direct search dan metode berbasis gradien.
Metode berbasis gradien membutuhkan informasi tentang gradien
dari fungsinya selama proses optimisasi berlangsung.
Gradien ini bisa dihitung secara analitik
atau diaproksimasi dengan kalkulasi finite difference.
Metode direct search tidak menggunakan informasi gradien
dan memakai strategi lain untuk meminimalkan cost function.
Beberapa algoritma optimisasi yang paling sering dipakai
di dunia komputasi kuantum adalah optimizer-optimizer berikut ini.
COBYLA adalah singkatan dari constrained optimization by linear approximation
dan merupakan algoritma optimisasi yang bebas gradien.
SLSQP adalah sequential least squares programming,
yaitu algoritma optimisasi berbasis gradien.
SPSA menggunakan vektor gangguan stokastik
untuk menghitung aproksimasi gradien dari cost function secara simultan.
Di lingkungan tanpa noise, optimizer seperti COBYLA
dan SLSQP terbukti konvergen lebih cepat daripada SPSA.
Optimizer klasik punya parameter tersendiri
yang bisa kamu atur untuk kasus tertentu, misalnya ukuran langkah.
Parameter-parameter itu biasanya bisa ditemukan di dokumentasi
yang berkaitan dengan optimizer spesifik tersebut.
Aku sarankan kamu cek daftar referensi di bawah untuk perbandingan
optimizer klasik yang paling mutakhir.
Sekarang mari kita jelajahi satu fenomena lagi yang berkaitan
dengan optimisasi klasik pada parameterized quantum circuit.
Seperti yang kita lihat sebelumnya, gradien cost function yang menghilang bisa menandakan
bahwa optimizer terjebak di dataran tanpa fitur yang menarik, yang disebut
"barren plateau."
Barren plateau bisa disebabkan oleh banyak faktor.
Gradien cost function yang terkait dengan sebuah quantum circuit
dengan parameter yang diinisialisasi secara acak
meluruh secara eksponensial menuju nol seiring bertambahnya jumlah qubit.
Ini karena ruang kuantum yang dijelajahi optimizer
membesar secara eksponensial saat jumlah qubit meningkat.
Cara-cara untuk mengatasi masalah ini antara lain dengan mengurangi jumlah parameter
dan dengan demikian dimensi dari ruang yang mendasarinya.
Cara lain untuk memahami asal-usul masalah barren plateau
adalah sifat agnostik-masalah dari parameterized circuit
yang menghadapi ruang parameter yang sangat besar secara eksponensial.
Merancang circuit yang disesuaikan dengan
masalah yang sedang dikerjakan bisa jadi solusi yang bagus.
Selain ruang parameter eksponensial yang memicu barren plateau,
fenomena fisik lain juga bisa menghasilkannya:
noise dan dekoherensi yang ada dalam eksperimen komputasi kuantum,
ekspresibilitas keseluruhan dari parameterized circuit,
atau nonlokalitas dan tingkat entanglement dari cost function yang dimodelkan.
Mengatasi tantangan-tantangan ini masih jadi area penelitian yang aktif.
Setelah kita tinjau komponen-komponen utama VQE,
kita akan merangkum algoritmanya di video berikutnya.